you go away my baby food no you put it
under here
you're genuinely it's great okay oh wait
let's Cheers no no no no you know your
leg is different now you're kind of hurt
hurt you know these two bozos I'm
choking those guys we should have videos
on their channels that are thrilling to
say the least every year that we do my
drunk pumpkin I try to pair it with some
sort of like costume challenge video and
so this year is no different except that
I spent way too much money I knew it I
spent a lot of money at Party City to
make this video happen for all of us she
didn't plan ahead and get the cheap one
off Amazon she at the last minute Party
City where they jack up the prices in
October because they know you'll pay
anything to get that [ __ ] minion yeah
I tried to get a [ __ ] toilet and it
[Music]
was a man and like it was a person that
like you just it wasn't it was a toilet
I will go back I will get it each year
we basically have done this like stopped
where this a bunch of like resources and
we make costumes based off it I have six
very sensual Halloween traditional
costume excuse Fergalicious with our
delicious Fergalicious we're each gonna
pick two and then we are gonna have 15
inch minutes Oh to take all of these
very large
we're gonna like Frankenstein in these
costumes together to make something
that's a little bit more complex a
little bit more dumb wait Kay I don't
know why I'm so nervous right now but
this makes me nervous
you have only had baby food drink your
stock yeah I just want you to get as
creative as you possibly can
Frankie's signing two costumes together
and we're gonna see what we come up with
okay what two together
oh I thought we just took one yeah we
have six so we're each gonna get oh
there are two rounds got it no two
costumes one beautiful result ish choose
your first costume they know you'll pay
anything to get that [ __ ] minion
heartthrob
okay so mine are zombie and a blast not
Wow
my Glenn together beautifully you
couldn't meet two man and woods thank
you gonna make something more creative
than this thing to get or can I just
squander it technically yeah we planks
for me week's video so I would love for
a little bit of effort 15 minutes timer
starts now
if it like dropped where we steal what
we need oh man and then wait for
inspiration and I'm gonna try on this
behind the camera so first I'm gonna
start by making some I was routed to the
camera you know in times like this you
just got to do what the person thanks
what what if you don't have one
Oh God we have a 12 bird oh my god
minute for three minutes it okay we're
gonna say literally three minutes don't
let my cackling disrupt sorry guys I
don't learn Harry Potter real fast it
can be whatever you want it to be we
have ten minute oh okay that's a thing
okay you look beautiful char son have
you ever been more proud
[Music]
okay
[Music]
stop it and a half minutes left
[Music]
just take it out great you beautiful I
am beyond string oh my god making me oh
[ __ ]
four three two one bang take it a big ol
sip of my drink I was all distressed
yeah I in my business no yeah glitter up
her on a level of one to ten how
stressed are we've I go right penicillin
but she's like happy little trees
Barbara style you know me yeah man
Hannah explain to us what York New
Frankenstein calm so I'm serving full
Galactic earth warrior I care about the
planet I love it and I will do anything
bend it in style
wow this outfit like our planet is
fragile so it's very impressive from the
front and not some wack you definitely
look like someone who gets kicked off
the first episode of drag race thank you
they're like yeah but like impressive
nonetheless like silver looks good on
you so what is the name of this galactic
earth warrior princess oh yeah okay
Oh oh hello sorry I interrupt your
currently scheduled shenanigans to plug
a company that will help you support one
of the people that are involved in your
currently scheduled shenanigans we're
talking about audible today baby you
guys know I've worked with this company
for so long and today is a very special
day because not only do we get to plug
audible for you as something that can
benefit your life but we get to support
a friend if you don't know audible has
the world's largest selection of
audiobooks and audible entertainment
including audible originals and I quote
audible originals are stories created
exclusively for audio including
documentaries exclusive audio books and
scripted shows that you can't hear
anywhere else if anything that's just
proved that I could read with the
exclusive audible app you can listen
anytime anywhere it's on mobile it's
Alexa enabled it's on Bluetooth it is
better than I and now if you become an
audible member you're gonna get more
than you ever did before every month you
get to choose one audiobook download
regardless of price isn't this fun as
well as two audible originals from a
fresh selection you also get access to
exclusive guided fitness and meditation
programs so this might be the Fountain
of Youth
for you so you guys start listening with
a 30 day free trial by going to
audible.com slash grace you get one free
audiobook download and two free audible
original downloads go check it out or
text grace to 500 - 500 and here's the
best part of all Hannah Hart you might
remember from such videos as the one
that you're currently watching has a
brand new cookbook out my drunk kitchen
holidays and she reads the entire
cookbook on audible so what a perfect
moment for you to go over support that
little sprout listen to her talking to
you about recipes it's heartfelt
and that's the pun that's it that's the
pun all the links are down below
yay Hannah yeah there's and best of luck
to you following along with the rest of
this video because it's real journey I
had a nun and a B cost about me so I
decided if we're gonna serve the planet
to save the bees so this is a camera
like planet Earth and like this is this
nun that is filming how long he's
getting saved on planet Earth Wow yeah
it's uh it's on BBC surely any message
shakiness yeah and I couldn't get it to
stand up alone so that's how we all need
to support it I like the environment
it's so beautiful yeah can we guess what
we think you are sure Miley Cyrus
bangers era for my
no no you Dora the explora Griffin Dora
the Explorer Gryffindor they explode now
and teaches kids how to spell Hogwarts
teaches spells like you know one this is
incredible
- have you thought of cutting your hair
no because I know it looks cute right
now but normally it's like if it goes
above my shoulders I look like I got
something baby you mean save the bees
[Applause]
and this is how we've organized you'll
see more of this at Hana show in New
York City all gonna be together for one
night only in Brooklyn yeah we all did
our best that's all we can do man I hope
endured entertained you so this is made
for a children's arm make sure you go
look at the videos with Nana and
memories channels that we show up to
make also go get Hanna's books itself
now it's loud it's province holiday
themed and it's got all your like a
cooking holidays you know us a burger I
want them to come to our show actually
Trevor twice second the merger New York
that's the show that Hannah has that
Grace and I are going to be at we don't
know what it's gonna be but me man thank
you guys for watching Mike's video
thumbs up and otherwise I'll see you
guys next time I don't know army crawl
everybody sees that right
the purple you're the perfect gem ring